merci beaucoup là merci beaucoup alors
regardez ce que je vais vous montrer là
c'est incroyable une scène de guerre
l'invité du soir on vaevenenir sur ces
vidéos c'est arrivé il y a quelques
heures d'une attaque au mortiers qui a
eu lieu ce matin dans un lycée du 8e
arrondissement de Lyon incroyable une
douzaine de jeunes ont lancé des tirs de
mortiers d'artifice à seulement quelques
mètres du proviseur de l'établissement
on va en parler ce soir avec Pierre
Olivier maire du 2uxème arrondissement
de Lyon et conseiller régional donc il
va tout nous dire vous allez voir on a
aussi des audios de ce qui s'est passé
d'un élève au sein de l'établissement
qui a accepté de nous parler c'est des
image de fou regardez bien ces images
ces tirs de mortier regardez Monsieur le
Maire c'était fou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez non mais c'est incroyable
certains ont filmé la scène de
l'intérieur du lycée j'aimerais qu'on
mette ces images derrière moi après bien
sûr en
off sur la production
si 20h57 regardez
c'est
ouf ils ont pas l'air regarde il regarde
ça
comme incroyable c'est des images d'une
violence inouie c'était ce matin 7 et on
voit que les élèves s'apprêtaient à
rentrer et donc il y a une douzaine de
jeunes cagoulé pour la plupart qui ont
tiré au mortier ils ont tiré sur les
élèves et sur le proviseur truc de fou
sur Olivier merci d'être avec vous maire
du 2è arrondissement et conseiller
régional donc c'est ce que dit ce qui
s'est passé ce matin oui c'est ça en
fait moi j'y été tout à l'heure à la
rencontre du proviseur il faut savoir
qu'on a une quinzaine d'individus qui
sont arrivés autour de de 7h20 et qui
ont tiré au mortier sur le proviseur
faut savoir que sur ce lycée vous avez
une une première entrée qui qui
correspond à peu près une entrée de
parking et derrière en fait avec la
région on a installé des porties de
sécurité ce qui fait que la première
salle d'attaque s'est fait sur la voie
publique les deux suivantes sur le
parking et le proviseur m'a dit c
protégé avec son parapluie parce que
malheureusement ce matin il pleuvait à
Lyon et et c'est vrai que ça a été des
scènes de Guera le le proviseur était
choqué mais c'est pas la première fois
que dans ce lycée on a ce ce type de
problème et donc j'espère en tout cas
qu'on va trouver des solutions c'est pas
la première fois c'est ce que nous a
expliqué cet élève au sein de
l'établissement qui bien voulu nous
parler il dit que c'est pas la première
fois qu'il y a ce genre de scène dans
son lycée devant son lycée ou dans son
lycée regarde donc moi je suis arrivé
c'était aux alentours de 7h40 j'allis en
cours et donc
j'arrive sur une rue qui donne face au
lycée et donc sur le coup au début je me
suis pas plus inquiété que ça parce que
c'est pas la première fois que ça arrive
les autres fois cétait surtout au moment
des grèves une manifestation un peu
violente ouis donc c'est pas la première
fois que ça arrive c'est ça qui F ouais
puis là de de ce que m'expliquait le le
le proviseur c'est que en fait on a on a
aussi installé des caméras de vidéo
prototection dans l'établissement et les
caméras nous ont permis d'identifier un
individu en tout cas qui était sous le
coup d'un d'une procédure disciplinaire
pour justement des desffet de violence
dans le lycée donc le proviseur pense et
j'espère que que c'est pas ça mais
derrière il s'agit là de représ
justement on pense que c'était le
Proviseur du lcé qui était visé et c'est
ça qui est extrêmement grave estce que
pouvez nous raconter ça oui alors le
proviseur a écrit une une lettre où il
dit j'ai été expressément visé par une
agression violente et en fait comme l'un
des deux interpellés faut préciser que
la police est agi très très vite comme
l'un des deux interpellés et l'un des
deux élèves qui doit passer en conseil
de discipline la semaine prochain alors
l'un des deux au moins c'est un élève
qui doit passer en conseil de discipline
la semaine prochaine Gabriel Atal vient
de le confirmer il pense que un des deux
interpellés c'est celui qui passe en
conseil et donc visiblement ils ont
voulu se venger du proviseur et là où
c'est terrible c'est que vous savez les
mortiers d'artifice parfois on tire en
l'air il y a eu des tirs tendus à 6 m
sur le proviseur qui avait son parapluie
c'estàdire que c'est un miracle on est
d'accord c'est un miracle que le
proviseur n'est pas été grav BL passé à
quelques centimètres il m'a expliqué que
les les les trois premiers tirs parce
que le temps de déployer le parapluie
l'ont l'ont frôé et et ce qui est
dramatique et vous évoquiez que
justement deux individus ont été
interpellé et moi je remercie encore la
police nationale qui a agi très vite
mais malheureusement parce qu'il n'y a
pas de caméra aut tour du lycée parce
que c'est la politique de la ville de
Lyon on n' pas la capacité à retrouver
les 1 autres parce qu'on aurait pu les
suivre avec les caméras et
malheureusement on l'a pas donc j'espère
qu'on aurindividus entre 12 et 15 c'est
les chiffres en tout cas que j'avais
tout à l'heure en étant sur place Al
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se passa avec cet
élève Gilles ah c'est des violences le
proviseur l'a convoqué en conseil de
discipline parce que c'est un élève qui
pose énormément de problèmes c'est un
lycée public où où il y a une certaine
population de jeunes difficile voilà ça
c'est sûr mais là il y a un élève qui a
dépassé les bandnes il est convoqué et
visibleblement il a voulu a priori avant
le conseil se venger ou mettre la
pression ça ne marchera pas mais ou se
venger agresser physiquement le le le le
proviseur hein cétait un lycée qui a
beaucoup qui a très bien marché pendant
des années parce que vous aviez
l'équivalent de 20 % de boursiers et en
2019 il y a eu la carte a été revue la
carte scolaire et ils sont passés à
quasiment 60 % de boursiers donc avec
beaucoup d'élèves de milieu défavorisés
et en tout cas c'est pas une raison pour
pour attaquer un un proviseur évidem on
a un des élèves donc qui nous a parlé et
c'est é extrêmement violent des gros
feux des explosions écoutez donc
j'arrivais là donc je vois grand ni de
fumée on voyait même les flammes d'où
j'étais il y avait quand même un sacré
feu beaucoup de monde à Troupé et il y
avait quand même un gros feu TR les
trtinettes étaient dedans il y avait des
explosions je sais pas si c'était les
batteries ou quoi mais ça pétait dans le
feu jeis tombé sur ouais sur une vidéo
avec les tir de mentier j'avoue que
c'est impressionnant surtout que c'était
visé sur l'établissement j'ai vu comme
quoi ça avait déclenché un feu aussi au
sein de l'établissement donc c'est pas
très rassurant quand même on se demande
pourquoi ils font ça enfin l'utilité de
faire ça quoi 12 jeunes donc entre 12 et
15 jeunes ont attaqué le provisour du
lycée à coup de mortier d'artifice
plusieurs poubelles ont également été
brûlé devant le portail de
l'établissement oui oui il y eu des
incendies pouBell trottinettes
électriquees dont les batteries ont
flambé donc voilà c'était une attaque en
règle et vous avez utilisé tout de suite
le bon mot c'est une scène de guerre
devant un lycée voà un guetarpent une
embuscade tendu au proviseur devant son
lycée il savait qu'il arrivait vers 7h20
le proviseur tout était calculé ils
étaient là et dès qu'ils l'ont vu ils
ont tiré et donc du coup il y a eu des
scènes de panique heureusement aucun
autre élève n'a été blessé mais c'était
clairement la personne physique du
proviseur qui était visé par des
agresseurs ultra déterminés et d'une
violence inouie ils étaient même arrivés
avec des des jéicanes d'essence pour
mettre le feu aux poubelles et aux
trottinettes électriques des des
explications que l'on a en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on a vu ce matin non mais
c'est le proviseur il est dans quel état
actuellement bah moi de l'échange que
j'ai eu tout à l'heure c'était en début
d'après-midi je dois reconnaître une
forme de résilience de la part de de de
ce proviseur parce que lui ce qu'il me
dit c'est que ce qui compte c'est la
sécurité de ses élèves c'est la tenue de
ses cours il m'a dit qu'à 8h les cours
on ont repris comme si de rien nétait et
ça c'est grâce au travail qu'il fournit
c'est grâce à la résilience du monde
académique et et en tout cas moi je je
me réjouis de cet état d'esprit malgré
le le le contexte extrêmement tendu et
je tiens à le redire mais c'est vrai
qu'avec la région vernonalp et
laurenvoquer son président on a beaucoup
investi on a mis 102 millions d'euros
pour mettre des portiques de sécurité
euh pour que chaque élève badge avant
d'entrer ce qui nous permet de d'assurer
ben la sécurité de nos élèves et
d'ailleurs on l'a vu parce que les les
porties de sécurité ont empêché les
individus de pénétrer à l'intérieur de
l'établissement et on a aussi des
caméras et c'est les caméras du lycée
qui ont permis de retrouver les deux
individus que vous avez évoqué monsieur
oui une équipe de sécurité régionale qui
a agi très vite qui a réagi très vite en
appui de la police donc ça c'est bien il
y a eu un
double qui a permis d'interpeller alors
ils ont quel âge c'est ah ben on sait là
je sais pas encore C en tout cas soit
première ou terminale mais je pense
qu'on parle d'un d'un adolescent ouis 16
adolescent donc qui qui qui a voulu Z
alors est-ce qu'ils sont connus des
services de police ou pas du tout pour
l'instant enfin qu'il con j'ai pas
encore les les les profils on sait juste
que l'un devait passer en conseil de de
discipline et il a été clairement
identifié par Gabriel LAL donc c'est que
le le le gouvernement est au courant et
que la police a déjà pu identifier mais
moi je n'ai pas encore la précision
alors oui qu quelle serait la qu'est-ce
qui risque ça ah bah là ils sont le
parquet a ouvert une enquête pour chef
de violence aggravée dégradation
participation à un groupement en vue de
commettre des violences si ça va au bout
ils peuvent risquer jusqu'à 8 ans ou
même 10 ans de prison éventuellement
avec les tirs de mortier comme ils sont
mineurs ce serait divisé par deux donc
s'il avait une peine ferme Infiné il
pourrait faire plusieurs années de
prison sils étaient condamnés voilà si
alors juste il nous a expliqué les qu'on
a eu donc au sein de l'établissement
pourquoi que selon certains élèves comme
vous l'avez dit cette attaque serait lié
au conseil de discipline d'un des élèves
c'est vraiment la piste privilégié hein
voilà écoutez donc là on aurait appris
comme quoi il y en aurait eu un qui
aurait dû passer en conseil de
discipline ou qui est passé je saais pas
qui aurait bah pas organisé ça mais qui
aurait participé euh et du coup c'est
pour ça que ça aurait été que cette fois
ça aurit été en direction de
l'établissement ouais il y aurait une
rumeur comme ça comme quoi ce soit ça le
conseil de discipline normalement selon
les élément qu'on a devait déboucher sur
une exclusion de cet élève voilà c'était
un élève qui était jugé néfaste pour le
lycée donc est-ce est-ce qu'il a voulu
déjà réagir à ça dans quelle situation
psychologique il était est-ce qu'il a
voulu se venger comme ça du proviseur
mais voilà il allait être viré du lycée
c'était sûr donc on on fait quoi avec ce
garçon pour vous ah ben moi j'espère
qu'il sera condamné de manière ferme tir
de mortier tendu sur improviseur il y a
eu plusieurs attaques récemment comme ça
là il faut être d'une fermeté absolue
honnêtement et on est on est si je puis
dire très heureux que le proviseur ait
pu faire cette lettre exemplaire aux
parents d'élèves en leur disant j'ai été
visé mais cyil là on pourrait parler
d'un proviseur dans un état très grave
si M tir de mortier enfin le Pier aurait
pu arriver Gabriel a réagi il a dit
l'attaque qui a visé le proviseur du
lycée à Lyon est profondément révoltante
l'un des meneurs l'un des meneurs de
cette agression interpellé devrait
passer devait passer prochainement au
conseil de discipline donc il a voilà
dis ce qu'on y donc c'est donc bien
l'autorité de l'école pour laquelle je
me bats qui est ici défié l'autorité de
l'école on ne la conteste pas on ne s'en
venge pas on la respecte je ne déviris
pas de cette ligne et continuerai à
soutenir l'engagement des sanctions de
sanctions disciplinaires à chaque fois
que nécessaire mais il n'y a pas de
sérénlité sans fermeté soutien absolu au
proviseurs à la communauté éducative de
Lyon et à tous les agents de l'éducation
nationale engagé pour nos élèves donc il
a pris donc Gabriel Attal en plus a pris
le le le le le le sujet en aujourd'hui
il est si c'est C si si si on sait que
c'est cet élève façon il ser il pourra
pas il va il va pas rester dans ah non
non non non ah non non non mais là il
peut aller all en prison C c'est c'est
très grave et c'est bien que Gabriel
réagit tout de suite il a pris la mesure
de la de la dangerosité de ce qui s'est
passé la région a réagit le rectorat
l'Académie parfois on dit l'éducation
nationale c'est la grande me rien ne
bouge là ils ont bougé tout de suite
mais Cyrile les images derrière vous
elles sont ahurissantes quoi c'est des
tirs de mortiers tendus honnêtement moi
je vais dire le mot c'est fait pour tuer
proviseur j en prison en fait il ira
jamais en prison bah si parce qu'en fait
en France c'est le pays d'Europe où où
il y a le moins d'incarcération de de
jeunes de mineurs c'est 1 % donc en fait
c'est presque inexistant donc en fait il
n'ira pas en prison ça faut quand même
qu'on se le dise pourut être honnête
là-dessus un vrai problème en mais de
redress est mur fait que au sujet
d'avant le sujet d'avant je vous ai dit
les gens toute impunité ils foutent le
bordel les mes foutent le bordel en
toute impunité parce qu'on a des
problèmes pour faire appliquer les
règles là vous avez faire quoi avec si
vous l'attrapez là vous l'explusz de
chez lui ça sert à rien c'est c'est la
justice qu' faut remettre c'est un peu
le sujet un mec qui a foutu le bordel
sur une place handicapée qui a mis le
feu là on va pour tuer un improviseur
comme dit G on rentre encore une fois
plus dans l'école respecte rien mais là
il a une regardez il y a une attaque
similaire qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui au
lycée condoré à Limet dans les ivelines
un élève a publié cette story sur les
réseaux sociaux pour vous dire c'est un
truc de fou regardez dans un autre lycée
[Applaudissements]
pareil
et il y a quelques jours au lycée Jean
Rostand Mantel jolie un individu cagoulé
s'est présenté devant les grilles de
l'établissement et a allumé un mortier
puis a tiré en direction de la proviseur
aussi regardez VO là c'est des
baisésment ça la parole de Gabriel Attal
était extrêmement importante et il était
évident important qu'elle soit dite tout
de suite parce que pendant très
longtemps les proviseurs comme le
personnel éducatif s'est senti
complètement seul et lâché à la fois par
les par l'électorat et C Y il y a un ami
qui me dit frérot tu le sais il y aura
rien blabla ils auront des heures de
travaux général d'intérêt général c'est
la justice française ça part en
suissette qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça enfin moi à titre personnel je sais
j'en ai parlé avec mon collègue maire
juste à côté nous en tant que maire
parce que je suis maire à côté on on
connaît la plupart des des élèves de nos
écoles on ils viennent régulièrement en
mairie et moi j'ai déjà eu le cas d'une
trentaine d'individus qui dévient et on
convoque les parents on convoque les
élèves et ensemble on trouve des projets
c'est-à-dire que certains ben oui on
leur tape sur les doigts sans forcément
de grosses sanctions mais derrière on
les aide à prendre des cours de soutien
scolaire on les change de club de foot
on les change d'école enfin c'est un
accompagnement personnalisé et puis si
ça marche pas bah on va un petit peu
plus loin avec des sanctions comme
l'évoquer mon collègue sur sur le
logement parce que ça peut être aussi un
levier pour que l'élève revienne dans
justement euh quand l'image que je vous
ai montré il y a un instant auodycée
monlageudi l'individu cagoulé c'est un
mineur de 17 ans qui avait récemment été
exclu de l'établissement aussi mais
exactement le même procédé tir de
mortier tendu vers l' provoviseur
cagoulé mêm âes sans doute donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a peut-être ou une
récurrence ou que eux se sont inspirés
de ce qui s'est passé à Mantel jolie
qu'ils avaient vu sur les réseau donc ça
peut être une inquiétude majeure parce
main à la mode pardon c'est devenu à la
mode pour attaquer les gens de sortir
des mortiers ou c'est ce qui est
terrible enfin si on tire au mortier à
tir tendu sur les proviseurs où est-on
comme vous dites on marche sur la tête
et là c'est fou moi moi je ne désespère
pas qu'ils seront condamnés à de la
prison honnêtement vu la gravité vu
l'émotion non mais on peut tuer surtout
avec un oui c'est ce que j'ai dit il
aurait pu mourir leiseur pour l'instant
il y en a deux qui ont été interpellés
un qui fait partie du lycée à prori au
moins quand on est sûr oui il est
identifié c'est celui qui devait passer
en conseil de discipline donc et qui
devait être exclu donc il est il fait
partie prenant du lycée voilà mais
aujourd'hui les proviseurs ils sont en
danger alors ouais mais en danger de
mort tir tendu de à 6 m et tous
lesèv sûr donc aujourd'hui l'école c'est
un danger l'école est un danger les
chefs d'établissement et ce chef
d'établissement qui est là qui qui qui
prend une mesure disciplinaire au
conseil de discipline il veut virer un
élève perturbateur on veut lui faire
peur on veut le menacer parce qu'il a
osé agir en tant que proviseur c'est ça
qui est inacceptable c'est intolérable
dans une école de la République ce matin
àoniseur visé par des tirs de morti dans
son lycée si vous nous rejoignez c'est
un truc de fou incroyable un élève donc
qui voulait a priori se venger parce
qu'il passait en conseil de discipline
mais il a voulu faire quoi est-ce que
vous voulez est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
a
voulu on va pas dire est-ce que c'est un
homicide par qu'il va êre jugé pourquoi
ça qui est important estce qu'il a voulu
c'est un homicide
voilà violence il a voulu faire quoi il
a voulu faire un coup de pression il a
voulu vraiment blesser ou tuer proviseur
c'est quoi réféch je crains le pire sur
12 personnes cagoulé une embuscade le
matin ciblé à 6 m en B organisé pour moi
comme il passait devant ce proviseur en
conseil de discipline la semaine
prochaine il y a pour moi un risque ilil
est voulu éliminer le proviseur qui
voulait le virer faut je dis les mots
qui qui n'engage que moi
mais nous en tant que collectivité on
essaie de développer je le dis avec la
région on a développpé ce que je vous
expliquais les porties de sécurité les
caméras et là on expérimente et
notamment on le fait avec les écoles
juives qui sont beaucoup ciblées en ce
moment les boutons d'alerte ce sont des
boutons très discrets qu'on peut avoir
dans la poche des enseignants des des
des chefs d'établissement pour que
derrière on ait une une une action
directe des services de police et voilà
je pense qu'on doit tous travailler en
commun c'est l'État les collectivités
locales et c'est ensemble qu'on arrivera
à trouver des solutions vous imaginez
tous les profs qui bossent avec un
bouton dans la poche sur lequel ils
appuent SS sont en
danger merci à tous merci merci à tous
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous tout de suite
c'est le son de la ville sur C
merci